Hi, everyone, and I'm excited
to be here to show you
a connection live between Google
BigQuery and Tableau Online
right here on the web.
We're in Tableau
Online right now,
and we're looking at several
dashboards that are connected
live to Google BigQuery.
Let's click into one.
What we have here is a
set of data from Twitter
that we've been collecting with
a number of different hashtags,
including BigData
and other hashtags.
It's collected by Gnip
Twitter's analytics engine.
And we did select
on a big data set,
and we've got all this data
right here in the dashboard
that we can look at live with
Tableau Online and BigQuery.
Now, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go ahead and filter
down to the last--
actually, let's go down
to the last day or so of data.
So now we're looking at the last
day of data in this data set,
and we've been looking
for tweets with text IOT.
But I'm more interested in
tweets with text Google.
And so now what we've got
is we've got dashboard
about when people have
been tweeting in this data
set, which is all the tweets,
as well as about Google,
which are the yellow tweets.
We've got several views here.
This one tells us that Google
has been tweeted in about 5%
of the data set
here about big data,
and we can see a scatter plot
of all the tweets and all
the users who are
using this term.
Now I'm going to just
click in to the ones that
are using Google.
And now you can see all of
these tweets that have been
posted in the last day or so.
We can hover over one and
look at what the tweet was.
In this case, they're
saying Google BigQuery teams
with industry leaders.
See how many friends and
followers this person had.
And follow all the tweets
and the social media
about the Google events
that are happening
over the next couple of weeks.
So what we're
working against here
is a live BigQuery data set.
Let me show you a little
bit more about that.
If we click into Tableau Online
again, and look at the data
sources, you can see
that I've actually
been working against this data
source called tweets from Gnip,
and it's a live data source.
And if I want to take
another closer look at it,
I can see that the
credentials for this data set
were actually embedded
right into the data source.
Now, I can edit
that and ask users
to put their own credentials
in, but in this case,
we're going to go ahead and
keep the embedded credentials.
So working with
Tableau Online, you
can actually publish BigQuery
as a live data source
or you can publish workbooks.
And once you've got the
data source published,
you can even go in and
create a new workbook.
So let's do that against
this Twitter data set.
And now you see a drag
and drop environment
that Tableau has that
lets you explore the data.
On the left, you see
all the different fields
in this data set
about Twitter data.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go ahead and look at the
hashtags in this data set.
I'm going to drag
that out to rows.
And Tableau is doing a live
query against Google BigQuery
to try and look at
all the hashtags
that are in this data set.
Now I want to see
how many tweets there
are for each of these.
So I'm going to take number of
records, and in this data set,
every record is a tweet.
I'm going to drag
that to columns.
Now I can sort down and see
what the biggest hashtag was
and bigdata is the
biggest hashtag.
It is the one that
we were pulling on.
I can do a couple of fun things
like change the color here.
And I can add things like the
actor display name to the view.
And what this lets
me do is it lets
me break down each
one of these bars
into the different Twitterers--
the different people
tweeting about the hashtag.
So I can click and I can
see that NoSQL-- the account
NoSQL-- tweets a lot of times
with the hashtag #bigdata.
That makes sense to me.
I can tool tip over
another area and I
can see that there's
somebody else tweeting
a lot about big data with the
display name egbertvanwinkley
and IAREGANG.
So these are some accounts
you may even follow.
And we can also see
related hashtags here.
We've got cloud and health care
and a few other things as well.
Now, one of the nice
things you can do here
is you can go ahead
and filter based
on when these tweets happen.
So I'm going to go ahead and put
posted time into a filter here.
And I'm going to
filter again live right
in the browser against a live
data set of BigQuery tweets.
I'm going to filter to the last
few days-- the last two days,
in fact.
06/08 to 06/10, and today
happens to be 06/10.
And now you can see, again,
the graph has changed.
We've got less data
in there and we're
looking only at the tweets
in the last couple of days.
Now, with Tableau you can
do a lot of different things
with your data.
One of the things you
often find in data
is location information--
geographic information.
So I'm going to go
ahead and double click
on location country here.
You see a little globe by it.
And what that is telling me
is that Tableau has identified
country as a geographic field.
And when I click on it, I
can see the location of all
the places where I have tweets.
Now, I'm going to go back
to number of records,
and I'm going to go
ahead and double click
on that to add it to the view.
And I'm going to go ahead
and crank up the size here.
And you can see that the United
States has been the place where
I've had the most records.
But I want to show you
another neat thing you can do.
When you're working
with data, you often
want to change perspective.
And Tableau's Show Me tool
lets you do that simply
by clicking in and choosing
another visualization that
might be appropriate.
We also have a
handy back button.
So if you want to undo
something, you can do that.
You can actually undo or redo
as many steps as you'd like.
But I happen to like
this view right now,
so I'm going to go ahead and
save this as a new workbook.
And I'm going to
call this tweets
on big data in this same
project and embed the password.
Tableau Online is a fully
secure analytics product,
so you can make sure that you're
enforcing the security that you
have on your data.
And now when I go back
into Tableau Online,
you can see that I've got
that new workbook here--
tweets on big data-- that was
updated just a few minutes ago.
That's just a taste
of what you can
do with Tableau Online
and Google BigQuery
when you establish a live
cloud-to-cloud connection
between this
powerful data source
and an analytics
product in the cloud.